yes
with ratings through the floor CNN
showed its boss the door true he tried
to fix fake news now is singing the
unemployment Blues Senate chairman and
CEO Chris Licht is out after just one
year on the job sadly he lasted about as
long as a Cinnabon and Whoopi Goldberg's
dressing room
the mission was simple recover ratings
and regain the public trust by ditching
their agenda driven journalism in other
words stop being CNN but Chris's tenure
was marred by the embarrassing failure
of CNN plus high profile spats with
anchors and mass layoffs the reality
Chris was canned for spearheading CNN's
biggest success in years the Trump Town
Hall
[Music]
it was their first ratings win in ages
and it was great it's great TV and yet
Chris is out because it's not about
great TV at CNN it's about keeping those
at CNN still suffering from Trump
derangement syndrome happy and they just
hated when that evil orange man brings
them so many eyeballs
so who will replace Chris
Heaven help them if it's another
straight white male am I right you can't
do that they certainly have options if
they go pure diversity
maybe this guy
or this one
the obvious choice obviously Dylan
Mulvaney
this bud's for you CNN
and so we say goodbye to Chris Licht he
barely we barely watched e let's take a
look back at some of his finest
achievements at CNN
despite a short tenure as CEO of CNN
Chris Licht achieved a number of
accomplishments including the firing of
Don Lemon also in April of 2023 he fired
Don Lemon and notably he fired Don Lemon
he even went so far as to fire Don Lemon
Did we tell you he fired Don Lemon
oh and also Brian stelter
Kaylee you're the only CNN Alum here I
think tuben outlasted
um the CEO is that necessarily Fair wait
out lasted was that a joke
anyway uh look no not fair at all but
CNN needs a tagline which by the way I
left voluntarily I guess I'm one of the
few uh Washington Post is democracy dies
in darkness CNN needs to be where you go
to commit career suicide you got stelter
uh you got Chris licked now you got
Chris Cuomo and then you've got my
favorite Don Lemon who by the way has
the only had the only late night comedy
show that rivaled yours true because it
wasn't comedy but if you viewed it
through the lens of Comedy as one of his
three viewers which sometimes I did it
was actually hilarious yeah he was great
even even the morning show was a laugh
Riot just watching the Expressions on
their co-host faces I'm sure that
happens to you Todd oh you should see
Carly's face every time I say something
she's mortified for one hour a day it's
beautiful are you kind of sad that we
never really got to learn how to say his
last name correctly licked licked I'm
assuming it's licked look like looks
like he got licked yeah I mean what's so
insane about all of this Greg is let's
call this what It ultimately was I know
there's this article out there people
say he got fired for the article got
fired for Ratings he literally tried to
turn CNN into a fair and balanced
Network and got run out by the inmates
that are running the asylum yes he
literally got run out by these people
because all they want CNN to be in the
current day and age is against Trump and
against Republicans against Trump one
against Republicans part two the irony
about all of this the guy who really is
in charge of CNN is the guy named John
Malone right he is extremely
conservative and he has asked that CNN
be right down the middle he has asked
but he hasn't like forced his hand it'll
be curious to see if the next CEO that
goes in there is ultimately tasked with
making it down the middle and if that
happens if they're going to be out in a
year as well it is a mess over there I
think what they're going to do is
they're going to keep who's ever
temporary in there what they would call
a staff favorite that's always the
person that is least competent the staff
favorite and then they'll just go manage
the network into a decline do you think
it's fair he only had a year did you
need more than a year to kind of like
grow and into your job cat you were how
long were you at Boston Market
um I was there for a couple of months
and I quit right before Thanksgiving
[Laughter]
[Music]
or a shopping mall Santa and quitting
like December 25th
take that children no but I had gotten a
higher paying work as a waitress I was
like I'm making minimum wage and tips
holy
I was so excited oh good uh yeah I think
we cannot underestimate just how few
people have any idea who this is yeah
yeah most people don't I mean all of us
are kind of paying closer attention but
I feel like the only time we're ever
really talking about something at CNN is
when there's massive turmoil yeah where
someone gets fired or people are just
really really mad so I don't I don't
know I think that they tried to go to
the center more but I don't think
anybody really cares because they went
so far to the left I don't think people
on the right are gonna watch
um and I think the only person that
would be the most bad about this
probably would be Don Lemon right yeah
he's probably like if I could have just
lost two more months yes
well thank god there's no turmoil here
keep that in
Jamie your wife fired you from being CEO
of your family
that's hard yeah I wasn't going to read
that question but I had to any advice I
was like bye no I was never really in
charge
um
I feel bad don't you I feel a little bit
bad for the guy this guy had no shot
this would be like being hired to be the
captain of the Titanic right after the
guy's like is that an iceberg
um like he had no they set up and
they're just trashing him and he was on
the sinking ship one guy said um the end
it's the end of a chaotic tumultuous
time that was doomed for failure from
the beginning one guy said they already
had a replacement in mind the whole time
those cliff notes for my marriage
[Laughter]
I just read the correct one this is the
same
it was the same thing
this might seem like I'm switching
subjects great but I wanted to tell you
um I love your Father's Day card and I
would take one if my kids celebrated it
um
but you know sometimes in these in these
hard times I I record a message yeah to
help to help people oh do you have one
to hear I do have one oh let's do you
happen can we play that
[Music]
lesson
lesson from a divorced dad
guys quick tip do not go see a therapist
that you think is super attractive
you just spend a bunch of money and say
a bunch of stuff that's not true because
you're trying to bang her okay
[Music]
never we're truer words spoken hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else